ми путіло сьогодні у такі робочій групі
за інформацією оскільки вати і ви означає
і як ми лаємося дали за постановою
стипендій на муз
ви знаєте, що за 1 7 pro прийняти бюджет
у нас стукнуло нам необхідний ви значить
якщо щоб давид booba ти сиди
адже стипендіями у нас буваєте від і
через я їх видно робота з міністерством
фінансів та міністерством соціальної
політики міністерству свитою наука пе-2
тувалу проект постанови
щоб її суб'єктам вниз і не ті й
порожня але ви відразу мило що з я кількома
проект я клей ми будемо про говорю ось і
для нас важливий його ваша думка ми запити
і душити якуїба що прийшов у доступних
міністр фінансів Сергій Михайлович
ми робимо і так пішов у нас присутності
заступниця міністра перший заступник
міністра соціальної політики від і ми
зможемо побачити по видним че нам купу ти
реакцію з їхніх міністерств і так само
запросив і представляти IV столітті і
активними у сфері кутку гориня
харчування реформи стипендій на вас
забезпечення топ то не заощадження до вас
просто статус-кво і я який суп або
стічні поля give a реального поля
tunatic та травня but is правді стипендій
нaс забезпечення його на балу мод і в затишку
зубному боці викладала свою про війну
функцію ми розуміємо у що консерватори
ситуацію так як ви є сьогодні а
самий що стипендій та малу низьку та
віями ж мінімальні сходи підсумок
то душа добрий навчається
е в mather але і вчені мотику і до
такого навчання його з порожнім ми їх
міністерство свитої наука та суб'єкти
внесення такої та постанови пропан у нього
свою weasel ми не будемо вузла чого ти з
центральним органом і влада і хочемо
купу ти так само тонко і членів робочої
групи дозвольте я вам за 1
15 побачив представлю уже живу халява і
наш пік хіт велика вісь що з фондом
стипендій 2016 уроки вівці я був
стипендіальний фонд суті вони степу
індійці було ну цілих чотири десятих
мільярда академічний трейсі
сімнадцятому роті нахабному кішки на
стипендія бірж і нас правді закладу
ми теж як йому міністерство фінансів у
зачіп червоних троянд підняв лише соціальним і
економічним і ступай ми так і що
ми поважаємо у що
кільки з кішки на академічному
пандіти, що розбив ти міністерство
фінансів у процесі дискусії снам та
прийшло нас у стриг і за 1 е в
принципі вирішення протези соціальних
стипендій на академічні будуть
перекинута oriental але одну тягнути
чотири десяті мільярди гривень - правді
кутили митися за раз вище і обожнювання вас
ловлю йому що щось було негаразд ціна
410 холодний тіла сім десятих
мільярдів гривень відсотка не досягала
їжу молодості я поясню чуму сама ця
цифра на 300 мільйонів більша я поясню
за роздали з приводу поп результату
вдалося ми проповідуємо і штук іншому
читами де джеки було так щоб перенесли
на академічні одну есе
поки що її димок думала не праворуч 1 і 4
частки
я фільму про позиції за розміром
стипендія кими по переднього умовляв
з міністерством фінансів по парі
втече і
мінімально найкраща на стипендію до 1100
гривень
противно соціально стипендія перетнути але
ми не можемо за розповісти про
міністерства соціальної політики будуть
також давати нам свої реакції по
соціальної стипендії
алеям ми поважаємо, щоб вона і я
ебло в новий малеча і менше ніш
академічно степу ідея цього рахунок
соціально гострим і через статус мені що
ти вчишся крадіжок театрі миша академічно
його на мої but i вийшли таким чином
тисячу oriental на гривень соціально
степан get nasty почуття академічно
далі види міни
вид мін і хто цей тип даної фарби я
зараз всі пси хто такий вид міни
багато концепцій за 1600 гривень ціна
ремені мінімальні заробітні плати і так
сама йому крему попередня нас харчування
для про креми спеціально став її на цих
ваш смак
надрукувати і куди нам треба мотику вати
крадіжок їх абітурієнтів цех природні
парних і не чини
спеціальності природні, ніж ця відмінність
інженер не так вже й pedal вуличний
природний ніж цьому а ти че у нас сьогодні
я проблема з вчителями математики та
фізики хімії біології там ваш членів
офісу та на туди за давньою студентою
welwyn їх через так і ми намагаємось на
тест будуть маток від вийшли на я
попередньому зарплату але на зарплату
гарну чоботи
цілитися дискусій нас ця цифра 2036 я
не чоловікові поясніть світлана самі вибрали
поки що офіціанток
знову любить звучання токто cr-v honda
молодший ну нахуй кофеїн
висока історія з третього четвертого
ременя гравітацією ями далі йшли
першому друрі
ревниво кредитування за професією
технічні освітлення
розумні взяв і спи вигляд ніж і якийсь сьогодні
і джейн і лише третім четвертим лініям
акредитації стипендій та колишнім другом
рім нам акредитації і з цієї н.д.
вибраний cs пиві навіювання виходить у
мінімальних академічних стипендій вид
по видимих ​​ланцюгах у початкових заході
Виходить, що в результаті прошу показати і у
хлопець вони далі друмирі ваня при
дотації я 20 ось на такі обличчя ти
підвішуватися практично так як це
в тому встигне ніж і не і до третього
четвертий renew прилітати та тут я
менше стати Індія кабула раніше і червоною
ці тести повернувшись із берією молитися
так само просто синьому технічного сміття
прошу показати тут є такі стипендії
злого 500 уникнення зберігаються
мінімально + 33 вид мінних + 72
т.п. доступні
чому питання про дані як що порохова
ти
значку 2 підходи збер їх ти ту ступінь я
дещо за 1 800 гривів то в такі розміри
степан дикі за раз і тугим на слух про
плані stp гени будуть дві третини d1 pick
it take to розмазати повідомлень ресурс та
інший пік хіт mouth його вати на та гарніше
і tedx хто найбільше зажадають цього у
нас є у тебе замість пензе для тих, хто
напиши зажадає і коли меч не для
мотивації я всі ми з робом у вас такий
висоти та троянда світ стипендія кірою
намотують там у нас буде 50 сотки
у студентки варіантів але розум соціально
економічних уривок із більше не довідки
щаблі
топ то половина студенти вікі будуть
надрукувати на бюджеті
будуть атр йому цей ступінь отрут тому
випад як всі пляшок і versin тому
такі нібито і
валу в не показані клею tiguan що
ширина випадкового жив його я хочу
показати на ступні слайд, що йшов рису
dance 4 суди з
кому треба яйця щаблі сьогодні стипендії
на даються тому в тумані середній бал
чітери
і проти і проці можемо від і
новачка
шивши одну 3-ку в результаті у нас ви
найкраща сну кільки з людей петля в ліцей
бал чітери
адже буває і різьбленим, а ні там злу
жування на сесії всієї процедури піцу
черевик і якщо давайте такі коди на
філософському факультеті я не хочу
тварині заради
образи тут відбувається не у філософію або
на філософському факультеті університету
можете вимагати 90 сотки
бюджетники ступенем, а вона на приклад
фізматі так написано різному
факультеті будуть відривати 32 сотки
випробувань те, що танки в чіпі за ваші ви
знайшли крин товари пресування стороні ми
то ми пропадаємо сифон і шипить хіт ми
ми тату ну йому рейтинговий і хіт при
треба не щаблі а самі критерії які
затвердівши для не стипендії для чого
для рейтингу
за твердіше і члена рада за отриманням з
органами студентського самоврядування
водне поло jevice ланцюга реле критеріїв
90 сотки у в'язницю критерії ми можемо
умовляти менше сперети ношу я наношу
думка правильно буде що 90 сотки
всім у критерію жити вісь оцінка
успішність спочатку а 10 адже сотки
вкласти та шукай показані на приклад
киргиз публікації жахливо у кого їх
конференціях спорт і поза дасінами вони шкіряні
вищий навчальний заклад
травня свої пріоритети діяльності за eg і
ми можемо і отже ці критерії
в результаті виходить так я до чого багато людей
відривав отримала четвергу вимиє йдуть від
до види скульптури для вирізування червоних
стоячи найкачиніше це гейб суму
адже рейтингу 45 сотки в студенті по
3-му і стипендію 45 адже сотки у піших
4345 тому що мова туди по 10 c будуть
гіти якима it сутності вони стипендії
так на сукна я думаю я думаю руку ну йому
перед його метою перехідний період тому
що у нас є у стену вищих початкових
закладі які
роблять сесії самого рудника а я часті
nike робік у чечні
пікнік я такий я цукерки я в купу не те
за результатом ці е з ці психі і
стипендію за новими правилами
покритий горіх за критеріями рейтингу
я йшов сесія у чечні
той той удіно вас тепер я ж буду аж
страв розуму
за новими критеріями і всі чисті теги я
за старим і провалом і
топ тоном увійшли, щоб результати нове
сесії ж проти новими
правилами не може ще клуб провалів
клана ся на стару стипендію так тону на
1 бік сесію а пішло навколо там у cc
наш пік it's заженуть кішка горець та для
міністерства соціальної політики, що ми
і зруби ви
було х при нами те, що я пропав ново але
у проекті і я і постанови ми взяли кі
категорії петьку видно далі ну ось
закону дасть вам і нічого не вигадував
його відрубав ісккон всі найкращі але
законодавства так це нарколога
соціальності співу та виписав і бійці
форель від презентації за вершину будь
ласка я прошу ставити про ітан і за
біля води та пропозицій
минулих
і
далеко ми можемо більше говоримо він і
вже
утворює w9
ти але
тут нас небагато тому можна кастувати
тут хороша куща каталіни випуск досвіду
за
і
тут те що ви про що ви проповідуєте
пише і академічно означає соціально 2000
гривень я вже немає шильди на 3 травня
ту соціальну стипендію витратити wright
сьогодні я хочу золоту валу що сьогодні
соціальні стипендії ви фініш академічно
склянку я сьогодні була його щит ми так ми
і так з рук було таким чином чого не
заразні фініші
і
судна гумові смужки
ооо
тимсі ньому був платним або мотики сука я
міг бути вона входить
у формі хотів skype е.а.
на міжнаціональних відповідаємо на сьогодні
овал і спеціальних такий
чи не ті ти по цьому синьому параболі
незаконно